من العراق سالنا الناس ما رايك في دراسه
تقول ان الشتائم تهدئ الاعصاب ماذا اجابه
نهائيا ما له علاقه اكو طرق ثانيه يعني
غير الشتم والسب وغيره فيقدر يهدي اعصابه
بها او يسكت اصلا يعني
والله تعتمد على شخص يعني هو حسب الشخص
واهله شلون ظروف تربى بيها يتعلم من
المقابيله بس هي بشكل عام يعني مو ضروري
يعني هذا الشيء يعني مو ضروري حتى الانسان
يهدا مو صحيح هذا يعني راح تاثر سلبي
بمستقبلا حتى لو كان الشخص يعني غلطان
بحقك الشتيمه مرهقه تكون حل سلبي
صحيح يعني
انا مرات العصبيه يعني
يصور هاي الطريقه يعني هو هو يتخيل هذا
الشيء انه راح اعتبره اعصابه وبعد ما
يستقر
[موسيقى]
احسب الدراسه انا بالنسبه يعني ما اعتقد
يصير يعني شتم اعصابي لا ما اعتقد انا
عصبي كلش ارتاح شويه اشرب مي اشرب يعني مو
بس ما شفتها
وغلط لا ما اعتقد الاعصاب اكيد لا يعني
هذا رده فعل وكل كلمه وتصرف يحكي يتندم
عليه فيكون لازم يعني بارد بهذا الموضوع
وما يحكي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات